Au début de la quarantaine, Adam Smith est
à Toulouse.
Vous le savez peut-être : cette ville est
aujourd’hui un des centres de l’enseignement
de l’économie en Europe (notamment grâce
à la Toulouse School of Economics [TSE]).
Mais au XVIIIe siècle, Adam Smith… se fait
chier à Toulouse.
Non seulement il ne trouve pas la ville intéressante,
mais en plus il ne reçoit pas les lettres
de recommandation qu’on lui a promises — ce
qui fait que sa vie sociale est limitée.
Il se sent seul et il s’ennuie.
Il rêve d’une excursion à Bordeaux, et
il cherche une occupation pour tromper l’ennui.
Alors pour tuer le temps, il commence à écrire
un livre.
Ce livre, c’est La Richesse des nations,
la première pierre de l’économie moderne.
L’Écossais du XVIIIe siècle Adam Smith
est souvent considéré comme « le père
de l’économie ».
Et son chef-d’œuvre, La Richesse des nations,
serait la bible du libéralisme parce qu’il
érige la liberté économique, la concurrence
et le marché en concepts fondateurs du capitalisme.
Mais il y a pas mal de choses qu’on ne vous
a pas dites sur Adam Smith…
Par exemple, il n’est pas économiste ; il
n’a aucune expérience du commerce ; et
ses grandes idées…
viennent de France !
Il y a un grand écart entre ce que l'on pense
savoir de Smith et la réalité.
Dans cette vidéo, je vais vous dévoiler
10 anecdotes surprenantes sur sa vie et sa
pensée, des révélations que vous ne trouverez
pas dans un cours ou dans un livre d’économie.
Restez bien jusqu’à la fin de la vidéo,
parce que j’ai percé le mystère de la
célébrité du père de l’économie, et
je vous l’explique dans les dernières anecdotes.
À l’âge de 4 ans, Adam Smith se rend chez
son grand-père et disparaît en chemin.
Il reste introuvable un certain temps.
Un homme rencontre une femme gitane dans les
environs.
Elle porte un enfant qui n’arrête pas de
pleurer.
L’homme trouve qu’il y a quelque chose
de bizarre, donc il envoie les patrouilleurs.
Quand ils tombent sur la femme gitane, elle
jette le petit enfant à terre comme un paquet
pour s’enfuir.
Les patrouilleurs identifient Adam Smith et
le ramènent chez lui.
Cette anecdote est un peu mystérieuse, parce
que le motif de l’enlèvement n’a rien
d’évident — la famille d’Adam Smith
est modeste, donc ça n’a aucun sens de
demander une rançon — et le biographe ne
nous dit rien de plus.
Il n’est pas impossible que l’histoire
soit en partie inventée et qu’elle exprime
simplement les préjugés de l’époque contre
les gitans.
Mais si je vous raconte cette anecdote, c’est
parce qu’elle illustre l’enfance plutôt
malchanceuse d’Adam Smith.
Son père, un avocat qui s’appelle aussi
Adam Smith, meurt quelques mois avant sa naissance.
Donc la mère d’Adam Smith va l’élever
seul.
C’est déjà pas facile à notre époque,
mais ça l’était encore plus au XVIIIe
siècle.
Adam Smith va donc grandir dans des conditions
modestes (je le signale parce que beaucoup
de penseurs sont issus de milieux privilégiés).
Mais sa mère va veiller à son éducation
et lui donner beaucoup d’amour.
Adam Smith disait souvent : « Je ne suis
beau que dans mes livres.
»
Au moins il ne se ment pas à lui-même : c’est
vrai qu’il est laid.
Les gens qui le connaissent disent qu’il
a un physique étrange :
un grand nez, des yeux exorbités, une lèvre
inférieure saillante.
Et pour ne rien arranger, il a un tic nerveux,
un défaut d’élocution, et même un tremblement
de tête qui serait né lors d’un burn-out
de lecture.
Bref, Adam Smith est loin d’être un beau
gosse charismatique.
Est-ce que ça explique quelque chose ?
Moi j’ai l’impression que c’est parce
qu’il avait un physique, et plus globalement
une présence repoussante, qu’Adam Smith
a développé ce qu’on appelait à l’époque
« le goût de l’étude », c’est-à-dire
une capacité supérieure de travail intellectuel,
en particulier de concentration pour la lecture
et l’écriture, et une certaine puissance
intellectuelle.
Comme l’extérieur est décevant, il a une
riche vie intérieure.
Et puis ça l’attache encore plus à sa
mère : il est fou d’elle ;
il est toujours resté très proche d’elle
;
et il a même vécu avec elle jusqu’à ce
qu’elle meurt, 6 ans avant lui.
Et du coup, comme le soulignait avec le sourire
Jean-Marc Daniel dans ses cours d’économie
à l’ESCP, « Adam Smith n’a connu aucune
femme ».
Dit plus directement, il est resté puceau.
Il n’aimait que sa mère.
Un matin, Adam Smith se retrouve à 25 km
de chez lui.
Les cloches de l’Église le ramènent à
la réalité en sonnant à 6 heures.
Adam Smith se rend compte qu’il est en chemise
de nuit.
Qu’est-ce qu’il s’est passé ? Il a
été enlevé par des extraterrestres ?
Non, c’est simplement un des traits de la
personnalité d’Adam Smith : il se perd
très facilement dans ses pensées.
On pourrait penser qu’il fait simplement
du somnambulisme, mais il peut se perdre dans
ses pensées dans n’importe quelles circonstances.
Ça lui arrive très souvent.
Par exemple, il participe à une conversation
animée lors d’un dîner, et d’un coup
vous le perdez, il est dans un rêve éveillé.
Un ami raconte qu’il l’a vu préparer
du thé avec un regard bizarre, et qu’il
a mis du pain et du beurre dans la théière.
Autre exemple : il visite une usine de tannage
et il tombe dans une immense fosse de tannage
(heureusement qu’il y avait du monde pour
l’aider à en sortir).
Bref, Adam Smith perd souvent le contact avec
la réalité.
Ça fait de lui un personnage excentrique.
Les gens qui le connaissent ont plein d’anecdotes
à raconter sur lui.
Et il semble qu’il ait été comme ça dès
l’enfance.
Il se parlait à lui-même, et il avait parfois
des conversations avec des amis imaginaires.
Cette anecdote montre que si Adam Smith est
laid et maladroit, il marque tout de même
ses contemporains par son originalité.
Nous sommes au début des années 1740 : c’est
la fin de l’adolescence pour Adam Smith.
Il étudie à la prestigieuse université
d’Oxford grâce à une bourse (il l’a
obtenue parce qu’il était un excellent
élève).
Un jour, un surveillant le surprend en train
de lire le Traité de la nature humaine de
David Hume.
Adam Smith se fait non seulement confisquer
le livre.
Mais en plus le surveillant le signale aux
autorités, qui punissent sévèrement l’étudiant
pour avoir consulté ce livre.
C’est quoi le problème avec le Traité
de la nature humaine de David Hume ?
Eh bien Hume, qui était un penseur des Lumières
écossaises, était un auteur subversif pour
les autorités religieuses.
Elles ne se donnaient pas le mal d’aller
dans le détail de sa pensée ; elles le stigmatisaient
simplement comme un dangereux athée
— donc comme Oxford était une université
liée aux autorités religieuses, il ne fallait
pas lire Hume dans son enceinte.
Cette anecdote montre qu’Adam Smith est
attiré par les idées et par l’attitude
intellectuelle des Lumières.
Il deviendra d’ailleurs une des figures
les plus importantes des Lumières écossaises.
Il est particulièrement réticent à l’égard
des questions et des obligations religieuses.
Il refuse de faire un cours pour défendre
la doctrine chrétienne.
Il fait scandale en souriant ostensiblement
pendant la messe.
Ou encore, il demande le droit de ne pas commencer
ses cours par une prière.
Bien sûr, cette attitude ne tombe pas du
ciel.
L’homme est toujours le produit de son milieu,
et Adam Smith gravite dans le milieu des Lumières.
Il est profondément influencé par Francis
Hutcheson, son professeur de philosophie morale
à l'université de Glasgow.
Or, ce prof fait de la philosophie avec une
grande liberté de pensée pour l’époque
(ce qui lui vaut d’ailleurs des ennuis).
Smith est également très proche de David
Hume, qui a une dizaine d’années de plus
que lui.
Enfin, Smith est fan de Voltaire, Rousseau,
et de Quesnay, un des économistes les plus
influents des Lumières françaises.
Au milieu des années 1760, des bustes d’Adam
Smith apparaissent dans les vitrines des librairies
de Glasgow, où il est prof à l’université.
Il a 37 ans et on vend déjà des bustes à
son effigie ?!
Mais attendez, son chef-d’œuvre, La Richesse
des nations, il ne l’écrit qu’une dizaine
d’années plus tard !
Je ne me serais pas trompé dans les dates
?
Eh bien non, je ne me suis pas trompé.
Parce qu’Adam Smith est d’abord une star
DE LA PHILO avant d’être une star de l’économie.
Il est prof de philosophie morale à l’université
de Glasgow.
Ses cours sont parmi ceux que les élèves
préfèrent, parce que Smith dit des choses
intéressantes pour capter leur attention
; parce qu’il s’écarte du programme classique
et qu’il évoque des idées nouvelles.
Mais sa notoriété explose en 1759.
Avec la publication de sa Théorie des sentiments
moraux, il devient immédiatement un des plus
grands écrivains contemporains.
Des auteurs célèbres font des critiques
élogieuses du livre : ils reconnaissent que
ses idées sont à la fois nouvelles et profondes
(j’ai résumé les idées essentielles du
livre sur le site 1000 idées de culture générale).
Dès lors, la popularité d’Adam Smith ne
cesse de grandir.
Ça devient la mode d’assister à ses cours.
Même les jeunes hommes de l’élite locale
qui n’en ont rien à faire de l’université
viennent écouter Adam Smith.
Des étudiants viennent de l’étranger pour
suivre ses cours.
Il arrive alors à Adam Smith ce qu’il arrive
aux gens célèbres : on se met à l’imiter
; à caricaturer sa voix et sa prononciation.
Mais surtout, son influence intellectuelle
grandit.
Ses idées, et plus fondamentalement son raisonnement
et son ouverture intellectuelle — qui sont
typiques d’un penseur des Lumières — se
répandent dans la jeunesse privilégiée
de Glasgow.
Je trouve que cette anecdote est cruciale,
parce qu’elle révèle l’origine philosophique
de l’économie : l’homme qu’on appelle
« le père de l’économie » était d’abord
un philosophe des Lumières.
Il n’était pas un mathématicien ou un
physicien — mais un écrivain avec une grande
culture littéraire.
Il s’intéressait aux questions économiques
en même temps qu’il s’intéressait à
la littérature et à l’art.
Pardon pour l’interruption, mais j’ai
une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
Le 18 octobre 1766, un des deux élèves dont
Adam Smith est le précepteur est assassiné
dans les rues de Paris.
Il a 19 ans.
Bien sûr, Adam Smith et l’autre élève
sont très affectés.
Ils rentrent immédiatement à Londres.
C’est la fin de leur « grand tour », ce
voyage prolongé à travers l’Europe grâce
auquel les jeunes hommes de l’élite occidentale
acquéraient une expérience pratique et des
compétences sociales qui n’étaient pas
enseignées dans les salles de classe.
C’est cette tradition qui a permis à Adam
Smith de vivre à l’étranger malgré ses
moyens modestes.
Après, il n’a pas réussi à être engagé
comme précepteur du premier coup, parce que
sa bizarrerie n’inspirait pas confiance.
Mais au début de la quarantaine, sa célébrité
change la donne.
Il reçoit une offre qu’il ne peut pas refuser
: couverture de toutes ses dépenses de voyage
+ le double de son salaire de prof d’université
+ le même montant comme pension mensuelle
à vie une fois qu’il sera revenu du voyage.
C’est une super offre, parce qu’à l’époque,
en Écosse, les profs d’université n’ont
souvent aucun revenu garanti — ils ont parfois
du mal à joindre les deux bouts.
Ils donnent beaucoup de cours particuliers,
certains jusqu’à la fin de leur carrière.
Donc Adam Smith accepte l’offre.
Avec ses élèves, ils se rendent notamment
à Toulouse, à Bordeaux (qu’Adam Smith
préfère largement à Toulouse), à Genève,
et surtout à Paris.
Ils y séjournent pendant un peu moins d’un
an.
Cette anecdote révèle l’influence des
Lumières françaises sur la pensée d’Adam
Smith, et donc sur la fondation de l’économie
comme discipline intellectuelle moderne.
En effet, à Paris, Smith rencontre certains
des intellectuels et des économistes les
plus importants de l’époque (même s’il
parle un français pas terrible).
Non seulement il a des lettres de recommandation,
mais en plus la traduction de sa Théorie
des sentiments moraux lui donne un certain
crédit.
Il se rend régulièrement dans les salons
littéraires les plus réputés et participe
aux mondanités comme jamais dans sa vie.
Il va souvent au théâtre.
En particulier, il fréquente beaucoup les
physiocrates.
Le fondateur de cette école économique,
le médecin Quesnay, insiste sur l’importance
de la circulation des richesses, qu’il compare
à la circulation du sang dans le corps.
C’est ce qui inspirera à Adam Smith sa
défense du libre-échange.
Comme je vous l’ai dit, Adam Smith est fan
de Voltaire.
Mais ça ne l’empêche pas d’aimer aussi
l’ennemi de Voltaire, l’autre pôle idéologique
des Lumières françaises, Jean-Jacques Rousseau.
Adam Smith a même de l’empathie pour Rousseau.
Il regrette ses problèmes, ses déménagements
répétés, et son anonymat forcé.
En 1782, Adam Smith dit à un ami français
: « Un jour, le contrat social vengera Rousseau
de toutes les persécutions qu’il a subies
de la part du pouvoir.
»
Le père de l’économie prédit la Révolution
française.
Au début de la décennie qui va changer l’histoire
de l’hexagone, il sent qu’un soulèvement
se prépare, et il sent que le soulèvement
accouchera d’une nouvelle distribution des
forces politiques inspirée par la pensée
de Rousseau.
Adam Smith se rend bien compte de l’oppression
et de la détresse de la population lors de
son séjour en France.
Il comprend que le pouvoir empêche les initiatives
de réforme, ce qui rend la situation explosive.
À ses yeux, si les Français sont plus pauvres
que les Anglais, c’est à cause de la fiscalité.
Il estime que la fiscalité française relève
de l’oppression : non seulement les impôts
sont trop élevés, mais ils sont injustes
et mal prélevés.
Après la Révolution française, l’idéologie
révolutionnaire sera en effet associée à
la pensée de Rousseau, MAIS AUSSI à celle
d’Adam Smith, en particulier à sa doctrine
du libre-échange.
Voici ce qu’il s’est passé lors du dernier
cours donné par Adam Smith avant qu’il
ne quitte Glasgow pour sa mission de précepteur.
À la fin du cours, il tire des enveloppes
de ses poches.
Et dans ces enveloppes, il a mis les sommes
correspondant aux frais de scolarité de ses
étudiants — en tout cas, au moins à ce
qu’ils lui ont payé en trop par rapport
aux cours auxquels ils ont déjà assistés.
Il est réglo : c’est la morale commerciale
de base.
Il appelle le premier élève pour lui donner
son enveloppe.
Mais là, le jeune homme refuse fermement.
Il dit que l’instruction et le plaisir qu’il
a reçus d’Adam Smith sont bien supérieurs
à ce qu’il a payé — et que c’est lui,
en réalité, qui a une dette envers le professeur.
Et là, tous les autres élèves se mettent
à crier pour dire la même chose.
Adam Smith est très apprécié par ses étudiants.
Non seulement il est un prof intéressant,
mais il a des qualités humaines qui le rendent
très attachant.
Beaucoup de ses étudiants gardent un très
bon souvenir de lui, et le recommandent même
à d’autres familles.
Certains restent en contact avec lui en lui
manifestant un respect affectueux jusqu’à
la fin de sa vie.
Le jeune homme dont il a été le précepteur
— celui qui n’est pas mort — ce jeune
homme le considérera toute sa vie comme son
mentor.
Et c’est pareil avec ses amis, et plus généralement
avec ses connaissances.
Adam Smith est un homme agréable, facile
à vivre, qui suscite spontanément la sympathie.
Pour la petite histoire, il réussit quand
même à remettre les enveloppes à ses élèves.
Il les remercie ; puis il leur explique qu’il
se sentira mal s’il ne les rembourse pas.
Et alors il saisit l’élève le plus proche
de lui par le manteau ; il lui bourre l’enveloppe
dans la poche ; et il le repousse.
Tout le monde, dans la classe, comprend qu’il
faut prendre l’enveloppe.
Si les étudiants aiment beaucoup Adam Smith,
il y a quand même des frictions.
Notamment à propos de la prise de notes.
Lorsqu’Adam Smith remarque qu’un élève
prend beaucoup de notes, il l’arrête immédiatement
et lui dit : « Je déteste les scribouillards
».
C’est bizarre, ça.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi c’était l’inverse
: les profs nous poussaient à prendre le
plus de notes possible.
Et au contraire, ils s’énervaient si on
ne notait rien.
Alors c’est quoi le problème, avec Adam
Smith ?
Eh bien il a peur qu’on lui vole ses idées
!
En effet, la particularité de son cours,
c’est qu’il repose sur des idées originales
qui ne sont pas dans les manuels.
Et à l’époque, il y a des abus : certains
étudiants revendent leurs notes de cours
à des éditeurs,
et alors les idées originales du prof se
retrouvent diffusées dans le grand public
sans qu’il en soit reconnu comme l’auteur
(ni, bien sûr, qu’il soit rémunéré pour
son travail).
Certains libraires vendent même directement
les notes des étudiants dans leur boutique
!
C’est pour ça qu’Adam Smith est, comme
la plupart des penseurs des Lumières, un
fervent partisan de la protection de la propriété
intellectuelle.
Après, d’après certains biographes, il
n’empêche pas non plus ses étudiants de
prendre des notes — il surveille simplement
les abus.
Vous connaissez Margaret Thatcher ?
Elle a été à la tête du Royaume-Uni en
tant que Première ministre de 1979 à 1990.
Elle incarne le retour du capitalisme libéral
après les décennies de keynésianisme.
Et la légende raconte qu’elle avait toujours
un exemplaire de La Richesse des nations dans
son sac à main.
Le chef-d’œuvre d’Adam Smith est donc
UN SYMBOLE du capitalisme libéral.
Mais Margaret Thatcher a-t-elle lu ce livre
?
Très probablement pas.
En fait, les gens ne lisent pas La Richesse
des nations.
Il y a même une blague d’économistes qui
dit que « l’économiste qui a lu La Richesse
des nations… n’est pas encore né » !
Pourquoi les gens ne lisent-ils pas La Richesse
des nations ?
Et comment se fait-il que les idées de ce
livre soient pourtant si influentes ?
Réponse à la 1ère question : la raison
principale pour laquelle ce livre est peu
lu, c’est qu’il fait 1000 pages et qu’il
n’est vraiment pas agréable à lire.
L’expression est lourde — même parfois
maladroite — mal structurée, sans méthode.
Personnellement, je me suis arrêté au bout
de 300 pages.
D’après les propres amis d’Adam Smith,
c’est mal écrit — alors que le style
de la Théorie des sentiments moraux est bien
meilleur —
La Richesse des nations est mal écrit parce
qu’Adam Smith a dicté, tandis qu’il a
écrit lui-même la Théorie des sentiments
moraux.
Maintenant, réponse à la 2nde question :
en fait, les idées fondatrices du capitalisme
libéral qui sont dans La Richesse des nations
étaient déjà dans l’air à l’époque,
et ce livre est bien davantage le symbole
de ces idées que leur véritable source.
Au début, dans l’Angleterre d’Adam Smith,
le livre sert de caution intellectuelle aux
hommes politiques qui veulent libéraliser
l’économie.
Et il y aura même un décalage important
entre le contenu réel de La Richesse des
nations et l’idée que s’en fera l’opinion
publique occidentale.
Je vous donne deux exemples :
1) La fameuse métaphore de la main invisible
n’apparaît qu’une seule fois dans le
livre, dans un sens peu clair, alors que la
postérité en fera le concept majeur d’Adam
Smith.
Second exemple : Smith dit très clairement
que la division du travail abrutit les hommes.
Et donc il nous prévient que la croissance
économique se fera au détriment du bonheur
du peuple ; qu’elle sacrifiera l’épanouissement
individuel des ouvriers.
Ça c’est une limite importante que les
profs d’économie oublient de mentionner…
…probablement parce qu’ils n’ont pas
lu La Richesse des nations !
Adam Smith avait peur que ses élèves lui
volent ses idées.
En fait, il aurait dû craindre que la postérité
ne les déforme.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre.
Ce travail est vraiment formidable et passionnant.
»
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable.
J'étais un peu dubitatif étant donné le
prix initial mais je ne regrette pas, c'est
un vrai travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui ai une mémoire essentiellement auditive.
Le choix des thèmes et des chapitres est
pertinent et je trouve que tu as trouvé la
dose d'approfondissement parfaite ; à la
fois précis mais sans fioritures ! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme.
Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous bénéficiez
d'une garantie résultats : une fois que vous
aurez terminé le programme, je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous n’avez
pas acquis une solide culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.